[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
keeping it real real sandy - oh very
short reminder for us I want you to
imagine next time you're in a hotel room
and you're about to check out you do a
clean sweep in the room to make sure you
didn't forget maybe your toothbrush
maybe your phone charger maybe a small
little item or a bigger little item
laptop carrying case whatever the case
because you don't want to leave one of
your precious or not so precious items
behind but now what if you over stopped
[Applause]
what if you ended up putting paintings
on the wall you put some nice sheer
curtains you went and put your own
little plasma entertainment bowl system
you would be like you could he crazy you
were this jet there for a short I mean
amount of time a day or two now take
that and compare it to what Islam
prepares us for that this life as the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
the Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him told us that this life is
temporary and be in it as if you were a
traveler taking rest under a tree taking
some drink taking what you need to
sustain your body and then keep going
now you got to get out of that hotel
room you got to keep going
you can where you gonna put all this
stuff what are get into u-haul so you
take what you need now we're all guilty
sometimes of over consuming too much of
this too much of that the material
things so this is a reminder to myself
and my brothers and sisters in humanity
where much at a time we spend a lot of
time
buying things that we don't need with
money we don't have to impress people we
don't even like let's slow it down
remember as the Almighty is telling us
in chapter 6 of the converse 32 1 yo
what a double here are two who live in a
fella therapy
well hiya to dunya Allah even wallah
well a Daryl are headed to Hyrule Allah
Dina yet to Khun F at attacking or was
the life of this world but mere play and
amusement passing time idle time the
abode of the hereafter is far better
it's no comparison
Jenna is the place that ISA at least not
Jesus called people to prepare for Moses
call people to prepare for and all the
messengers of God by worshipping the
crater not the creation doing good deeds
establishing submission to the will of
God in your life Islam being thankful to
God grateful to God and preparing to
meet God by doing good deeds and by
doing those with these that's how you
get God's mercy and grace thank you for
spending a few minutes with me next time
you're in a hotel think about that Salam
alaikum with Allah peace be with you
subscribe if you haven't already
subscribe thank you for peace
[Applause]